the thing that strikes me the most about
watching a movie like strange world is
that inspiration creates even more
inspiration like this is keeping that
train going and I wanted to ask each one
of you what was
a noteworthy moment in your life when
you decided that animation was what
really captured your heart
that is a great question um
for me I think it was when I saw Dumbo
um you know uh and you know when I grew
up I I went
as I grew up I grew up in a small town
and I would go to the theater every
Saturday that was my my theater time I'd
ride my bike there and watch whatever
was playing and a lot of times it was
you know that was where I first saw like
Dumbo Pinocchio uh Peter Pan and
somewhere along the way I must have done
some research and found out that you
draw those films then and so then you
know very early probably five or six
that's I decided this is what I wanted
to do
I it was the 80s after school animation
shows or some like yes that was where I
was so glued to the television and there
was a lot of there were a lot of great
female adventure shows and I just I
never let it go I still watch them I my
daughter watches them now and that I
think that's the point for me I love
moments thinking about that like for
parents
just let your kid be glued to something
even though it might mildly concern you
because it you know that has grown into
this which is that's Magic
that's amazing what about you Roy yeah
it was I was in theater before I came
into animation and I had never thought
about going into animation and was
invited by a group of folks from Walt
Disney Animation to go see a screening
of Aladdin and I saw Aladdin and I went
oh my gosh this is the way to tell a
story it's just such an amazing
adventure and so it was really Aladdin
that kind of made me go yeah I think I
think I could work in animation
and I love the element of Aladdin too
that
is
withstanding the test of time almost
like a Looney Tunes Vibe where the way
that you understand it when you were one
age is different from the way that you
understand it at another
in a really Robin Williams amazing way
sometimes yeah and you know Eric
Goldberg who was the animator of the
genie is still working with us and
actually worked on this film
yeah he did a Splat test early on like a
2d because we were you know that was
going to be a big thing like how are we
going to move this little little critter
around and um and he did a an amazing 2D
test that also involved Winnie the Pooh
and I will leave it at that
okay we'll be on some bonus stuff
sometimes Beyond bonus yeah it'll be on
the bonus thing let's put a pin in that
because this could be an all Splat q a
by the way but we'll you know I'll
control myself but what about you yeah
for me my uncle would take us to the
Disney Thanksgiving movie every year and
so I grew up watching Disney animated
films but it never occurred to me that
that was a jab that I think it all just
seemed very magical to me so I fell into
animation my third year in college I
went to school to be a painter and then
took an animation course and totally
fell in love with creating characters
and telling stories with animated care
it's awesome what a life
you know and then and you get to see
this joy that you bring on the screen I
think it's a very specific kind of joy
as well I'm obviously totally biased in
doing this no absolutely I mean it is
like a Wonder because you know you're
you're speaking to kids from four to 104
you know and and it keeps the kid in you
alive which is really wonderful and I
felt like a real kinship with what I'm
calling the Pinker dactyls
I was like I was really sad at the
beginning of the movie I was like ah
darn they look like the bad guys they're
actually really sweet I think we should
rename them I like that yeah I do too
that's the best one I think we need to
read rename them now
you've heard it here first this is an
academy exclusive so
there's so many comparisons being made
to of course like Jules Verne and just
this incredible element of explanation
exploration that's really like ignited
everyone's in for in imagination but I'm
wondering if there was something of a
hidden influence that you had in mind
along with Qui that was surprising as
far as the movie goes because it's not
just an exploration movie this is a
family movie yeah I I um I don't
remember this Qui tells a story uh but
evidently when he first came in we met
um I pitched the movie as Indiana Jones
meets Little Miss Sunshine
so I um so I guess that was in there at
the beginning because you know I I just
love these adventure stories the the
Jules Vern of it all and even these
specific kind of adventure stories where
explorers find a hidden world I mean
they're you know I just love King Kong
being kind of the great cinematic
example of that but I love those kind of
stories but I also love
you know dysfunctional family you know
Journey movies and because this was a
generation this was going to be about
three generations
um of the clade family I just thought
that would be the you know we have the
adventure you know vehicle to propel us
but then the fun family Dynamics could
come out as well and so
yeah
we had a lot of fun doing that because
we all could drop on our own kind of
family stories to to put in the movie
yeah that's what makes films like this
so relatable we all we've all got them
and it you know I could imagine that the
holiday season after this movie takes
place for the family being like
considerably warmer than it would have
been before so good for them like
[Music]
um Sarah I would like to talk to you
about putting this movie together as
opposed to putting a television show
together
and I know that you were talking about
how television is like a is a newer
experience to you but what are the is
there is there kind of a Layman's
difference that you can explain to us
well for uh with feature animation
editing you really are on from
development all the way through to final
sound mix so I follow Don and Qui from
beginning to end in a sort of run around
in their shadows and make sure that
everything that they ever say is never
forgotten and with my understanding with
television animation is it that role is
really divided between two people you've
got someone who handles the storyboard
portion of it and then you've got
someone who handles the layout and the
animation so that gets divided a little
bit between two people who may not work
at the exact same time on the on the
picture but for me I'm this movie takes
over my whole being for many years and
uh and I and it's it's a real journey
it's from the seed to this beautiful
polished finely mixed sound designed
piece like I really get to watch it
evolve and I get to work with every
single Department along the way and
watch how everybody pluses and brings
their a game and all this amazing
creativity and just watch every little
Choice that's made by hundreds of people
turn into this beautiful film it's such
an incredible collaborative
collaborative effort film and I think
that my perception is that animation
teams are even closer as a family than a
regular crew or a live-action crew one
of the reasons for that is because a lot
of movies list like the babies that were
born during the production which I
always think is so amazing and I think
like oh my gosh they're sort of like
they get their own Credit in the movie
yes yeah it's amazing because you know
Don and I have worked together for about
25 years you know and now Sarah has been
with us for like four years and Amy I
know from Tangled so that's that was was
that your first film Tangled dinosaur oh
my God further anyway I mean it's it is
like like this Repertory company you
know and you get to know everyone's
personality their strengths their
weaknesses and it's it's it is a little
bit like the family in the film yeah
there's sort of a continuity of of
collaboration you know that happens
because we're all together and you know
we finish a film but you know we'll all
come back together again and work in
some capacity and so that that's that's
pretty amazing you know as opposed to
kind of scattering to the wind you know
we you know we've all we've all been
through the battles together and that
you know helps when you know things get
dicey as they do on all films late in
production you can always count on each
other because we've all been through it
together
now speaking of Tangled
I wanted to ask you Roy what is a
challenge that you had in the producing
world back then that was very different
on this film many years later
you know it was interesting because
Tangled was kind of our beginning in
terms of CG animation
and we were playing with a lot of the
technical needs of that and during
um Tangled we literally reinvented the
entire pipeline through lighting
uh so we didn't see any images really
finished images until about six months
before we released okay yeah we didn't
see any we you know we saw animation in
a rough form we saw but we never saw a
finished lit scene until about six
months before so that was this film was
actually a joy in the sense that we
didn't do any
um major technical rehabbing or there's
always little things that are going on
but it was really a craft it was about
the craft on this film uh we we never
struggled with technical but we had
these amazingly wonderful complex scenes
that just you know continued to kind of
evolve or the first scene that went into
production was the big chase sequence on
the back of what we call the what are
they called the the Goblins the goblin
swills the goblin swells that that
sequence was the first to go into
animation in the last to come out so
yeah that was the
toughest sequence in the film because
you have characters running on top of
other characters which is so difficult
to do but when you're talking about
collaboration earlier this was probably
the most collaboration we always have
collaboration on each of our films but I
think this was more than I've seen in
the past because so many departments
really needed to work together because
they were influencing each other thank
you so much for being here today and
thank you for watching out there strange
world is in theaters for you right now
and you need to make make sure that
everyone in your life enjoys the poop
pickles so give a hand please to Don
Hall Sarah Reimers Roy Conley and Amy
Smead my name is gray Drake and everyone
be well and happy holidays
bye-bye thank you thank you